here comes example two except I'm going
to use this same formula that we had
before the same equation right I've got
a equals PI R squared well I could
substitute for that on the pronumeral in
there for the a right so if I said
substitute rather than R equals one
color substitute a equals now I don't
know what that's going to be 225 times
pi is about two and twenty five and
three it's like seven hundred and 675
there abouts
okay so that's a really big circle which
I just got rid of I'm going to try and
take on a smaller circle so suppose I
had a circle and its area was 100 I'm
going to do it just like I did before
and I'm going to substitute it into here
okay so what I can do is if I swap out
that a the area pronumeral if I swap it
for the number I can use that to find
other things so I'm going to say 100
equals pi squared what line is this what
names did I just give to this line I put
it in orange this is the substitution
right right I've done no working out at
all but that's because I want to make
sure I substituted exactly correctly you
wouldn't believe how many mistakes
people make by trying to do a bit in
their head and then they do that bit
wrong and their substitution ends up
incorrect okay now at this point you
know kind of a nice thing to work out
would be the radius
maybe solve to find the radius so what
could I do to this equation we've been
dealing with equations since last year
that could help me get toward the
solution any suggestions so there's a
pie here right right here right and it's
kind of in the way of me having the
radius all by itself I don't really want
that pie there so what could I do to
both sides that would eliminate the pie
from the right-hand side hmm what do you
reckon sending
okay so I could divide now just before I
do what's a Hindu suggests which is a
great idea I want to ask all of you why
not
subtract like there's a pie there if I
take away pie with the pie be gone why
don't I just take away pie from both
sides can anyone tell me why that might
not be so helpful yeah what are you
thinking okay 100 minus pie on the
left-hand side so is there anything
wrong with having a hundred minus pie
doesn't that still get rid of the pie
why is it division as a Hindu suggesting
and not subtraction what do you think
your son ah so can you repeat that one
more time just so that everyone catch
it's really important very good so if
you didn't quite catch that right do you
remember when we were doing our
abbreviations for algebra before if you
don't need to write this down if you see
something like this 5a right that's
actually an abbreviation right what's an
abbreviation for what's missing there
that's actually implied yeah yeah
there's a multiplication as Krishna and
said there's a multiplication here and
there's also multiplication hiding right
there there he is
right so if I wanted to not have the pie
on this side I have to undo
multiplication right and I divide by
that not using subtraction does that
make sense if I was adding then I would
undo that by subtraction okay now that
was just established around his idea is
a good idea let's go ahead and do it
so I'm going to divide both sides by PI
like so okay that leaves me with this on
the left hand side what am I getting on
the right yeah just a squared there we
go now I don't know what a hundred
divided by PI is probably you don't eat
it that's what we have calculators for
us and it's stressing about that too
much but there's one last thing I need
to do to get just R I don't want a
squared I just want by itself what could
I do
yeah I can take the square root just
like the opposite of multiplication is
division the opposite of squaring is
take the square root okay so we'll go
ahead and do that
so I'm gonna put the R over here on the
left-hand side now because I'm gonna
finish this off and I've got the square
root of a hundred divided by pi okay now
just a couple of quick things to note
right you actually can get a negative
number out of this too if you squared
the negative of this you'd still get
that like someone told me why I'm going
to ignore that negative why don't why
can't I have a negative here why would
that be like a ciliates and a half what
am I trying to find out what's the thing
I'm solving for yeah just go anything
yeah very good so if you didn't catch it
right this R right and this comes back
to the very first thing that we wrote on
the board right this is a pruning rule
it stands in place of something in
particular so you have to think about
what's it standing in place of a radius
is a length you've got to be able to
measure it so this has to be positive so
you might like to write on the side here
with me ah is positive and I'm even
going to write the reason for that
because it's a length now just for
completeness could someone reach for
their calculator or you might already
have it there and can someone tell me
what the square root of a hundred
divided by pi actually is equal to maybe
we could get two decimal places of
accuracies anyone there
you've got an answer years you've got
can you tell me the square root is
someone put into their calculator saying
you've already given me a few good
answers today so let's see if we need
someone to get someone else to get their
area yes 5.64 do I get some agreements
and confirmation from you guys because I
actually do not have a calculator here
the calculator my brain can't handle
that so I'm gonna ask for you guys tell
me at five point six four to two decimal
places
by the way 5.64 is actually small enough
for you to picture on your page there is
a 5.6 for radius circle feel like it
should have an area of 100 centimeters
square centimeters I should say if I put
six four think about it look at on your
page five point six forward go sort of
mostly halfway cross yeah I'm pretty
happy with that I always do a sense
check when I'm done okay okay so here's
our last example now there's two
differences between this guy and the
ones that we had a look at before anyone
want to call out some of the differences
Mary what do you see well you're already
going to an answer let's let's let's
park that for a second I will get your
answer in a minute but um what
differences do you see between this and
the two examples we've just done any
takers ever give me one okay so there's
no play there's also no squared there's
no I could keep on going for this for a
while okay good can someone give me
another difference yeah I've got like
I've got like more stuff here right
remember over here I just had one number
to put in yeah
but here I've got a bunch I've got
actually I'm counting not four but one
two three
three things to substitute okay Louise
did you see something similar or
different oh yeah this guy here now
remember we said right at the front
pronumerals can stand for different
numbers well they can stand for any kind
of number that we like you could put in
fractions if you want to in fact I have
a decimal here so you like oh it's a bit
funny to deal with okay but that's fine
these can really stand for anything one
last thing I want to point out right I
gave you a equals PI R squared before I
was a formula it was an equation because
an equal sign it right have a look at
what you're substituting into right now
here it is is this an equation this is
not an equation how can you tell there's
no there's no equal sign which is where
an equation gets its name right but
that's okay you can still substitute
into an expression and you'll just get a
number at the end okay should we do this
together we're going to do the first
thing a minus B on to C I'm gonna do
that what's it called again
very
thing I do the substitution loan right
so even though I could simplify some
stuff in my brain I'm like I know what
for take away 1.2 is maybe you don't
that's ok but if you do I still want you
to do this line so I can see what you're
thinking so I can see you do there's one
and there's two
I can see you do the substitution does
that make sense this the numerator what
shall I write I might denominator 2
times 2 times yeah watch out for that
negative write the negative comes along
for the right so I'm gonna do
multiplication like that ok now you
probably know I'm like I know that's
equal to negative 6 but I still want to
see this substitution line laid really
clearly out now we can actually do some
calculations ok 2.8 very good divided by
negative 6 and I mean you could probably
simplify this is a bit weird having
decimals and that kind of thing maybe I
would multiply everything by 10
something like that ok we could we could
go to a decimal one of the issues where
the decimal here though is I bet it's
got lots of numbers trailing off the end
does it yeah and then it's like I don't
know so it's going to be approximate so
I'd like to keep it as a fraction
because fractions will stay exact can
someone help me out what can I do here
why can you divide the top of the bottom
by you do trick you get better than two
didn't go for that gives me 7 and 15 and
then this minus signs on the bottom
strictly speaking there's nothing wrong
with that but we tend to like them on
the top so I'm gonna write this final
line as negative what was on the top
again 7 over and that's exact same
pretty happy we're done okay